PROFESSOR: Let's
continue our examination
of GCD's and linear combinations
and Euclidean algorithm
by examining what's often
called the extended Euclidean
algorithm.
It's a good name for it.
Its ancient name, dating
back to ancient India,
is the pulverizer.
And we will see what
that does in a moment.
So the theorem that
is the culmination
that we're aiming for is
that the GCD of two numbers
is an integer linear
combination of the two numbers.
That is, the GCD of a and
b is simply sa plus tb,
where s and t are integers.
And what the pulverizer
enables us to do is given a
and b we can find s and t.
In fact, we can find s and
t virtually as efficiently
as the Euclidean algorithm.
It's just by performing
the Euclidean algorithm
and keeping a track of some
additional side information
as it progresses.
Now a corollary of this
fact is that we now
know that the-- if we
want to characterize
the linear combinations
of a and b,
they're precisely the multiples
of the GCD of a and b.
That's because we know that
every factor of both a and b
divides any linear
combination of a and b.
And therefore, the GCD,
which is a factor of a and b,
divides any linear combination.
So that means that any linear
combination is a multiple
of the GCD of a and b.
Of course, once we
know the GCD of a and b
is itself a linear
combination, it
means that you've got all
of the linear combinations
by taking multiples of the GCD.
How do we get s and t?
Well, the basic
idea is that we're
going to find these coefficients
by applying the Euclidean
algorithm.
And as we go, we're going to
be calculating coefficients.
And eventually, when
we're all finished,
we'll wind up with the s and t.
Specifically, let's remember the
Euclidean algorithm starts off
with a and b.
And then it has two registers,
or numbers, x and y,
that it keeps updating.
And the invariant is that
the GCD of the x and y,
that are being continually
updated by the Euclidean
algorithm, stays the same.
It's always the GCD of a and b.
So what we're
going to do is just
keep track of coefficients, call
them c, d, e, and f, such that
the x, whatever
we're up to, we know
how to express as a linear
combination of a and b.
And the y, whatever
y we're up to,
we can also express as a
linear combination of a and b.
So we're going to
be keeping track
of these four
coefficients, c, d, e,
and f that have this property.
This property is going
to be another invariant
of our extended Euclidean
algorithm, or pulverizer.
Well, how do we get initial
values for a c, d, e and f?
Well, that's easy.
At the start, x is a.
And so, c is 1.
And d is 0.
Because a is 1a plus 0b.
Similarly, y is 0a plus 1b.
So we know what these
values of c, d, e, and f
are at the start
of the algorithm.
The question is how
do we update them?
Well, how does a Euclid work?
Well, remember, at the
next step, the value of x
is the old value of y.
So if I had the old
value of y as ea plus fb,
then I clearly
have the next value
of x as the same
linear combination
that y had previously.
What about y next?
Well, at the next
step, the value of y
is simply the
remainder of x and y.
Well, the remainder
of x and y, remember,
is just x minus the
quotient times y
where the quotient is the
quotient of x divided by y.
So this is equal to the
remainder of x and y.
And that means that
since I also have
x expressed as a
linear combination,
this x minus qy is simply
this linear combination
for x minus the quotient number
times the linear combination
for y.
Well, the difference of
two linear combinations
is a linear combination.
So just combining
coefficients what I discovered
is that the way to express y
next as a linear combination
of a and b is just to combine
the previous coefficients, c,
d, e, and f with the
quotient in this way.
And that's all there is to it.
Well, let's work out an
example to see how it goes.
Suppose that a is
899 and b is 493.
These were numbers that
we had previously applied
the Euclidean algorithm to.
So now, what we're
doing is observing--
I'm going to begin by
calculating the remainder.
But this time, when
calculating the remainder,
let's keep track
of the quotient.
So I'm going to
find the remainder
of 899 divided by 493.
It's 406.
And the quotient is 1.
That is 899 is 1
times 493 plus 406.
What does that tell me?
Well, 406 then is-- remember
899 is a and 493 is b.
I'm discovering that the
first remainder, 406, is
1 times a plus minus 1 times b.
So now, I have that
first remainder
expressed as the desired
linear combination of a and b.
Well, what's next?
Well, now that I've
got 406 and 493,
I'm supposed to
take the remainder
of 493 divided by 406.
Well, that's 87.
In fact, 493 has a quotient
1 times 406 plus 87.
So that tells me that 87 is
this number minus that number.
87 is 493 minus 406.
Well, remember, 493 is b.
So 87 is 1 times b
minus 1 times 406.
But wait, look up here.
406, I know how to express it
as a linear combination of a
and b.
So let's replace the
406 by 1a plus minus 1b.
And what I'm going to
wind up with-- remember,
it's a minus minus, so
I wind up contributing
an a and an extra b.
And I wind up with
a minus a plus 2b.
Said that wrong.
The a is getting negated.
But you can check my algebra.
So there we are with the linear
combination that expresses
the next remainder, 87.
All right, let's continue.
After this, what
we're supposed to do
is find the quotient of 406
by 87 and the remainder.
So when you divide 406 by
87 you get a quotient of 4
and a remainder of 58,
which means the remainder 58
is 406 minus 4 times 887.
But now, looking above, I
have the coefficients of 406
for a and b.
And I have the coefficients
for 87 for a and b here.
And so, I have to multiply
those by 4 and add them.
I wind up that the way to
express 58 in terms of a and b
is 5a plus minus 9b.
And next, I'm supposed
to find the remainder
of 87 divided by 58.
The quotient's 1.
The remainder is 29.
And that means that 29 is 1
times 87 minus 1 times 58.
Looking back, I see how to
express 87 in terms of a and b
and 58 in terms of a and b.
I can just combine
those expressions
to wind up with 29 is minus
6 times a plus 11 times b.
Next, I have to take the
quotient of 58 divided by 29.
Well, the quotient is 2,
but the cool thing now
is the remainder is 0.
That's the stopping condition
for the Euclidean algorithm.
It means that the answer is 29.
There's no remainder anymore.
So the GCD of 29 and 0 is 29.
The final GCD, then,
we finished is 29.
But look what we got.
In the last step I
had expressed that GCD
as a linear
combination of a and b.
And that's the pulverizer.
I've just figured out that
possible values for s and t
are minus 6 and 11.
And this is a perfectly
general procedure
that will always give you
coefficients s and t that
express the GCD of a and
b in terms of a and b.
Now, sometimes it's
technically convenient
be able to control which of
the coefficients are positive
and which negative.
Clearly, if you're
going to combine
a and b that are
both positive numbers
and wind up with
a smaller number
by adding multiples of them,
one of those coefficients
has to be negative.
So in this case, we had the
coefficient of 89 was minus 6.
And the coefficient of b was 11.
And suppose that
I wanted, though,
the first coefficient of a
to be the positive number
and the other one
to be negative.
How can I do that?
Well, there's a pretty trivial
little trick for doing that.
It's ingenious, but it's
immediately verifiable.
How do I get a positive
coefficient for 899?
Well, there's a general way
to get new coefficients.
If you look at minus
6 899 plus 11 493,
if I add any multiple of
493 to the first coordinate,
and I subtract the
same multiple of 899
from the second
coordinate, all I'm doing
is adding 493 times k times
899 to the first term.
And I'm subtracting
493 times 899 times
k for the second term.
They cancel out.
So this linear
combination is going
to be the same as that one.
It's going to be the same GCD.
But now, by adding in any
multiple-- by the way,
k could be positive
or negative-- of 493,
I can make the first coefficient
as big or as small as I like.
In particular, if I
want it to be positive,
might as well take the
smallest value of k that works,
which is 1.
So if I let k be 1, I discover
that I add 493 to minus 6.
I get 487.
And I subtract 899 from
111 and I get minus 888.
And there we are with another
expression for-- this time
s is 487 and t is minus 888.
And the second one is negative
and the first one is positive.
It's going to turn out that
this little trick will enable
us, in the next
video, to come up
with a general solution to the
Die Hard bucket problem, which
is fun.
But let's finish up
the current story.
And the remark is that
the pulverizer is really
another very efficient
algorithm, exactly
the way the Euclidean
algorithm is efficient.
It's basically got the
same number of transitions
when you update the pair
xy to get a new pair, y
remainder of x divided by y.
So it's taking twice log to
the base 2 b transitions.
So it's exponentially efficient.
It's working in the length
and binary of the number b.
Of course, there's a few more
additions and multiplications
per transition for
the extended GCD,
or the pulverizer, than the
ordinary Euclidean algorithm.
So big deal.
It means that the number of
total arithmetic operations of
adds and multiplies is
proportional to the log
to the base 2 of b.
I said here 6.
I think it's actually like 10.
But the main thing is it's
a small constant times
the log to the base 2 of b.
The pulverizer is a very
efficient algorithm as well as
the Euclidean algorithm.
And those are going
to be crucial facts
that we'll build on.